jusqu'à 10 km de bouchons ce lundi matin
à rio de janeiro trois semaines que ce
n'est pas arrivé dans la ville carioca
la veille le maire marcelo krivets l'a
approuvé le redémarrage des activités
commerciales
car au brésil ce sont les autorités
locales qui prennent leurs propres
décisions sur le calendrier le processus
et des étapes de la reprise de
l'activité sociale terrain de football
bat restaurants et centres commerciaux
de l'état de rio de janeiro ont été
autorisés à rouvrir un déconfinement qui
pose question alors qu'avec près de
soixante dix mille cas la ville carioca
et sa région est l'une des plus touchées
par la pandémie au brésil deux
stratégies différentes en argentine où
le déconfinement du pays n'est pas
attendu avant le 28 juin
mais ce lundi soir joggeurs cyclistes
marcheurs et sportifs en tous genres ont
pu retrouver les rues de buenos aires s
après la levée des restrictions
concernant les activités physiques en
plein air il est temps de revenir 1
devant changer un peu d'air à même sont
enfermés depuis plus de 70 jours où je
ne sais pas combien de temps
91e mêmes et nous en avions vraiment
besoin pour notre santé et notre
bien-être aussi un confinement débuté le
20 mars est particulièrement stricte
port du masque obligatoire dans tous les
espace public y compris la rue demande
de ne pas prendre les transports en
commun et nécessité d'un justificatif
pour sortir de son quartier cole
suspendu
des mesures qui ont permis au pays
d'être beaucoup moins touché que ses
voisins brésiliens et chiliens au chili
justement pays où le nombre d'infections
par million d'habitants est le plus
élevé au monde
la population est confinée depuis 11
semaines un confinement difficilement
maintenu par les autorités qui ont
décidé de renforcer les contrôles
policiers dans les quartiers de la
capitale chilienne
nous sommes en train d'effectuer mission
dans le centre de santiago
parce que les gens ont été négligents
ils ont été responsables et nous avons
maintenant on semaine de quarantaine et
plus de 2000 morts un confinement devenu
également difficilement supportable pour
les péruviens deuxième pays le plus
touché du continent en quarantaine
depuis le 16 mars le perron a décidé de
la prolonger jusqu'au 30 juin soit le
confinement le plus long au monde
du lundi au samedi entre 21h et 4 heures
du matin et toute la journée du dimanche
la population doit rester chez elle
pourtant des millions de péruviens
continue de vendre des produits dans les
rues pour pouvoir survivre
une crise sanitaire qui se transforme en
crise économique
40% des péruviens ont perdu la totalité
de leur revenu
[Musique]